with the increase in the data exchange
between network channels
the need to understand data exchange
process becomes a necessity
but through which more does exactly the
network performs the sharing of data
this is what we will discuss in this
session on selective repeat aiq protocol
hi guys and welcome to yet another
interesting video by simply learn
but before we begin if you love watching
tech videos subscribe to our channel and
hit the bell icon to remiss an update
from us
now without further ado let's take a
look at the schedule for today's topic
to begin with we will do a quick recap
of sliding window protocol which forms a
basis of selected repeat arq protocol
then we will look into some details
regarding the selective repeat erq
protocol
moving forward we will also look into
some important points regarding the
protocol
next we have the steps involved in the
working of the srp protocol
as for the end topic we will look into
difference between the selected repeat
arq protocol and go back in on q
protocol
let's begin with the first topic that is
recap
sliding window protocol is a method to
share multiple data frames at a time in
a network channel
the frames shared in the network are
based on window sites assigned
beforehand in the network module
the window size is indicated by capital
n
in sliding window protocol and its
counterparts
let's take a look at the next point
each of the frames are assigned a
sequence number for transfer of frame
and also to achieve
more efficiency
if you want to look further into the
topic sliding window protocol you can
visit our video on the same
with the link in the description box
now let's move on to the next heading
for the session
and the next heading is what is
selective repeat arq protocol
for the first point in selective repeat
rq protocol we have is
the working principle
the working principle of the asrp
protocol is based on sliding window
protocol
and it uses a buffer system for storing
either at the center side or the
receiver side during the data
transmission
let's move on to the next point
for selective repeat arq
the term arq in the protocol defines the
automatic repeat request process that is
designed to perform the task of sending
the next frame for each of the
acknowledged frame
now let's move on to the next heading
next heading is important points about
the protocol
for the first point we have is
the value of n that represents the
window size is same for both sides that
is the value of sender size
is equal to the window size of the
receiver side
let's take a look at the next point
in case of selected repeat arq protocol
as the name suggests in case the frame
is not received by the receiver side or
the acknowledges not received by the
sender side
as shown in the diagram
in this case the mentioned frame is to
be retransmitted without affecting any
other frame
let's move on to the next point
for this heading
in case the frame is not received by the
receiver side then it will share a
negative acknowledgement signal
do the sender side so that it can
re-transmit the damaged frame
this point
forms the basis of the working process
involved in the srp protocol so please
take a note of this point
now let's move forward
with the working of the protocol
we'll divide the working process of the
srp protocol in multiple steps for
better understanding let's move on for
the first step
to begin with we have a sender side and
the receiver side as usual
then we have a sequence of numbers
and a window size
now for the second step let's send the
first data frame that is frame 0
next is frame 1
frame 2
and frame three
these four frames are sent for the
beginning because our window size is
four
and a sliding window appears from
sequence number zero to sequence number
three
after the receiver side have received
the sender sides frames it will
acknowledge the first frame that is
frame 0 and send the acknowledgement
signal to the sender side
after the sender side receives the first
acknowledgement signal it will again
share the next frame in the sequence
that is
frame number four
and the sliding window will shift from
frame 0 to 3
to 1 to 4.
now similarly
let's acknowledge frame number 1 from
the receiver side to the center side
and the center side will share the next
frame in the sequence that is frame
number 5 to the receiver side
and the sliding window will shift from
frame 1 to 4 to sequence number 2 to 5.
now
let's acknowledge frame number two
okay now let's assume that frame number
two is lost or corrupted during the
transmission
in this case if we apply go back narq
protocol
all the frames sent after frame number
two are to be retransmitted
that will be frame number two
three
four and five
but in case of srp protocol that is
selective repeatable protocol
only the frame that is lost during
transmission is to be retransmitted
that means
the acknowledgement signal for frame
number three will be sent from the
receiver side to the sender side
and the sender side will then retransmit
frame number two to the receiver side
this process of retransmitting only the
loss frame is known as the selective
repeat arq protocol
and similarly we will acknowledge the
next frame that is frame number four
and send the next frame that will be
frame number six
as you can see
in this process of srp protocol the
sliding window or the window size
clearly does not play any particular
role
with the completion of this slide we are
done with the whole working steps
involved in the srp protocol now let's
move on to the next heading in the video
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1 000 plus hours of
video content for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
the next heading in this session is
difference between selected repeat arc
protocol and go back in rq protocol
let's take a look
for the first point we
have in go back in lq protocol it does
not require a large amount of memory
as it does not provide the buffer
feature for the network model
whereas in case of selective repeat arq
protocol it requires a buffer system so
the memory needed is more on both the
sides that is the sender side and the
receiver side
now let's move on to the next point
all the frames after the lost frame in
go back in iq protocol are to be
retransmitted
as we already discussed in the earlier
slide
whereas in case of selective repeatacy
protocol only the damaged or the loss
frame is to be retransmitted
let's take a look at some other points
too
in go back in a give protocol too many
re-transmission frames are required so
the efficiency of the overall r model is
very low
and in case of srp protocol the
retransmission frames is less
so the efficiency of the overall model
is increased
take a look at the last point for the
difference
the bandwidth required for go back in a
queue protocol is too high due to the
more re-transmission frames
as for sap protocol moderate bandwidth
requirement is needed
with the completion of difference
between srp protocol and go back in our
queue protocol
we are completed with this session
if you have any questions regarding the
topic you can ask them in the comment
section
thank you for watching
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here